- [Instructor] Let's say, for some reason,
you had lent the government $1,000,
and so the government has given you
a formally issued piece
of paper that says,
"Hey, we, the government, owe you $1,000."
This is issued by the Treasury.
This could be a Treasury bond.
It could be a T-Bill of some kind.
And let's say that the Federal Reserve,
the central bank is interested
in inserting money into our system.
So let's say this is the
Federal Reserve right over here.
Federal Reserve.
And so what they do is they create
$1,000 of Federal Reserve Notes,
what we associate as paper money,
and they pay it to you
and they buy the Treasury,
so the Treasury goes to the
Federal Reserve from you.
And so, in an exchange, you
get this newly created money
that the Federal Reserve just created.
So, there you go.
You have, this is $1,000.
Now, what would you likely
do with that $1,000?
Well, it might not be
safe to walk around town
with your pockets bulging like that,
so a lot of folks would
deposit it into a bank.
So let's think about what would happen
to the bank's balance sheet.
So, you go to the Bank A
and I'm just gonna think about
what was the balance sheet,
the pre-existing balance
sheet for the bank,
but let's just think about
what happens to its assets
and its liabilities when
you make the deposit.
A for assets, L for liabilities.
If you deposit those thousand dollars,
then your assets for the bank
is going to get $1,000 in reserves,
but you didn't just give them the money.
They have a liability to you.
You should have a checkable
deposit account now,
so we could say checking account.
So now, you have a $1,000 checking account
which you would use an asset for yourself
but it's a liability for the bank.
At any time, you could come
and ask for that thousand dollars.
$1,000 checking account
and this would be for you.
Now, we've already spent several videos
talking about fractional-reserve lending
and there's two ways
we can conceptualize it
as we've seen in those videos
but I'm gonna go with the simpler version
of fractional-reserve lending.
And so this bank says,
"Look, we are in a world
"where our reserve requirement,"
I will do a reserve requirement.
This actually is a typical
reserve requirement.
The reserve requirement
in this country is 10%,
which says that the bank
only has to keep 10%
of these cash reserves
and then it could loan out
the rest, and so it does that.
That's its business model
or a significant part
of its business model.
And so, what it does
is instead of having $1,000 in reserves,
it keeps 10%, so it keeps $100,
and it loans out the rest.
And so, it loans out $900.
So, it's loaning out now
$900 to someone else,
hopefully someone who
is good for the money,
who maybe they're gonna
invest it into their business
or they're going to buy a
house, or whatever else.
Now once again, the bank just
didn't give them the money.
In exchange, they get an asset,
which is an IOU from that person.
That person owes the bank money.
They owe them $900.
So, we could say that in exchange
for giving 'em that cash,
they're going to have a $900 loan
on their balance sheet as an asset.
Now once again, the person
that they lent the money to,
the loan would be a
liability, they owe the money,
but for the bank, that's an asset.
"Hey, someone owes me, the bank, $900."
But then what's this person going to do?
Well once again,
their pocket's are gonna
bulge quite as much
but they still might not
wanna walk around town
with $900 in their pocket,
so they are likely to deposit in a bank
and they could deposit it in Bank A
or they could deposit it in another bank.
Let's call it very creatively,
Bank B, all right (chuckles).
So, Bank B, same exercise.
I think you might see where this is going,
so its assets, its liabilities.
And so they go and they deposit this $900,
so you have $900 right over there.
And the corresponding liability,
that person then give
the money to the bank,
that person can demand that money
at any point from the bank,
and so you have a $900 checking account,
checking account.
And that person would drop
on that checking account
to buy the machinery for their
business or whatever else.
But once again, we have a
10% reserve requirement,
which says that the bank
only has to keep 10% of that,
and so their business model
is they do only keep 10% of it
and then the rest of it, they loan out.
So, they loan out $810.
It could be a loan or it could
be multiple loans altogether.
And I think you see where this is going.
So, this is lent out to someone else,
so now we have $810,
which can then be deposited
in another bank, Bank C.
They can lend out 90% of that
and that process keeps going
on and on and on and on.
So, an interesting question
is given this infusion
of a thousand dollars
and given this reserve requirement,
how much total money has been created?
Well, in one other videos,
we talk about the multiple
measures of the money supply.
When the Federal Reserve put this $1,000,
a Federal Reserve Notes into circulation,
they increased the
monetary base by $1,000,
but one measure of the monetary supply
is, well, what are the Federal
Reserve Notes, the coins,
and the paper money that's in circulation,
plus the amount of checkable deposits,
and we talk about that
in other videos as M1.
And so, our M1 over
here, what's it gonna be?
Well, this person has a thousand
dollar checking account,
$1,000 checking out, they
think they have $1,000
that they can write checks
against and they do.
And this person has a
$900 checking account,
$900 checking out.
And then this person right over here
that when they deposit their money,
they're gonna think they have
an $810 checking account.
They have that.
And then that process, they're gonna go on
and on and on and on.
Someone else, when this
$810 gets deposited,
the bank's gonna lend out 90% of that.
That person's gonna think they
have that amount of money.
And so what we do
is we're just multiplying
by .9 every time.
We're multiplying by one
minus the reserve requirement every time.
And we've done the mathematics
on this multiple times.
This is going to be equal to $1,000,
the initial amount that was
put into the monetary base,
times one over
one minus 0.9
and that is just going to
be equal to $1,000 times
one over 0.1
or you could just view this
as one over the reserve requirement.
It just happened to be
0.1 in this example.
Reserve requirement.
And you could do the math
on what that's going to be.
One divided by 1/10 is going to be 10,
and so our M1 money supply
that has been created in
this very simple example
is going to be equal to
10 times the thousand dollars,
so it's gonna be equal to $10,000.
So, big picture.
When the monetary base is
increased by a certain amount,
if you know the reserve requirement
and if you assume that all the banks
minimize their reserves,
that they keep only the 10%,
they don't keep 11% or 12% or 20%,
then what this calculation
is gonna show you
is what is going to be
the maximum effect on M1
given that infusion
into the monetary base.
And all it is is the
amount that was infused
times one over the reserve requirement.